so the French have sent their Sprague's
back to the classroom in fact a lot of
continental Europe has the Brits are
still arguing about it but from Paris to
Copenhagen exhausted mums and dads who
were no doubt sick of hearing how bored
they're childless friends are and how
they've taken up knitting and Mandarin
are getting ready to take their kids
back to school and probably looking
forward to going to the toilet
uninterrupted for the first time in a
couple of months but your experience may
have decided to willfully ignore some
major questions for example how are they
supposed to control the spread of
coronavirus when they can barely control
nits playgrounds have reportedly been
made pandemic friendly so they've put in
markers to show the kids where they're
supposed to stand in order to socially
distance themselves from each other
which sounds great in theory but in
practice anyone that who hasn't ever
dealt with a five-year-old although that
spatial awareness or any type of
awareness for that matter isn't exactly
their Forte the great news is that
getting caned at least in the nan Ali G
sense is an even remoter prospect than
it was before the teachers were in touch
those German festered kids with a
bargepole now